it was nice to see this clip this is
from Fox News Marco Rubio who's my
Senator right here and I've done some
events with Senator Rubio I like him a
lot we've had him on the show a bunch of
times but he doesn't get much National
Fanfare these days I think he's kind of
laying he's been laying a little bit low
for for one reason or another
um but he did get on Fox and I think he
made a a completely clear and cogent
point about what is going on here you
know we showed you the video from two or
three days ago at the White House they
had this dude who is in women's body
plastic boobs and the whole thing
running around topless and Marco Ruby
addressed that and connected it to some
other things happening in the world
right now we can we can undertake a
cultural hysteria a ridiculous cultural
hysteria that plays out we had a lady or
a man that now claims to be a lady you
know going topless at the White House
two days ago at a Pride Celebration
thing I mean we can do whatever we want
can be as decadent as we want in our
society and our culture we can break our
politics we can take our institution and
weaponize them for political purposes on
both sides you think this ends here the
next Republican president is going to be
under tremendous pressure to bring
charges and indict Joe Biden his family
his crackhead son whoever the pressure
is going to be extraordinary they're
going to turn us into so we're decadent
and we're in decline because we are we
thought we could do anything we wanted
with our economy we could center jobs
and factories overseas break our
politics break our culture break our
society we don't need parents we don't
need a neighborhood we don't need family
anymore all these crazy ideas and now
reality is catching up and it's hurting
us badly and today is frankly just a
symptom of a much bigger problem what
you talk about here and that is we no
longer live in that world he's right we
thought we could do it anything we want
right and he's connecting that to we
thought we could do anything wrong we
thought boys could be girls we thought
we could do anything we want we thought
we could print money endlessly we
thought we could do anything we want we
could have military adventures all over
the world now reality is setting in and
we're looking around and going boy
people are depressed boy our economy is
crashing boy we're in wars that make no
sense we've got dudes in chick outfits
showing their tits
do we just get demonetized can you say
tits I should have said boobs I should
boobs is not going to get you
demonetized tits it's 50 50. anyway it
doesn't matter what are you gonna do
what are you gonna do
um the point of all of this guys is that
some people want to fight and the people
that want to fight whether they're Ron
DeSantis whether they're Kevin O'Leary
whether in this case they're Marco Rubio
whether it's you or me like we must
fight together
[Music]
thank you